fabian welcome to the show
thanks for having me
it's a fun topic
spirituality
accelerated
fabian you found
the channel through
uh no limit society is that right
no i've been watching you for quite a
while actually i think the first video
was with frankie
i think
like back in february or so
yeah something like that cool
nice
and then when did you join no limit
society
i initially joined the meditation
mastery retreat and yeah then just
throughout the week after three months
and now i'm hooked
that's so great
nice
cool
initially we were going to talk about uh
xrp
and eventually we probably will a little
bit more on on the show
um
and today we might actually touch on it
regarding how
the decentralized architectures are
actually accelerating the inner journey
but let's talk about
you specifically because you're 20.
yeah
and you're already tuned into
the vibe of
awakening
how did that happen
like for me it started
because of a great catalyst i would say
like in my youth i was pretty anxious
and
just didn't feel that great and i wasn't
accepting myself and
because of that i just feared for a way
out you could say
and initially i got into fitness and
working out and reading a ton of books
and
uh you could say building my intellect
to be really streamlined and then i had
this
intellectual identity
and that was already like a great shift
of okay now now i'm i'm great i'm
i'm worthy
um and then also covet was a huge
catalyst for me like it just pushed me
down again because all my the structures
i built that just destroyed like in one
swipe
and i was basically like at the bottom
again you could say
and
then
also a big part of psychedelics in my
journey
so i had a mystical experience you could
say and then i was like oh
i realized i'm conscious and it was like
this huge revelation because somehow i i
managed to overlook this my whole life
yeah but then
yeah i just oh wait a second i'm
conscious and i never thought about this
before how can i have this knowledge
with not thinking about it
then i got into philosophy and already
touched a bit about spirituality i
started guru and other you could say
more therapists like teachers
and like the biggest event
for me was actually this year
and i was walking outside
in the middle of the night
and it began snowing and i'm living like
it's not really the city it's more like
their transition from city to village
and somehow there appeared messages
written in the snow on on like the roof
of car
and it were my thoughts
and in different languages and
it was just not explainable to me
so like my my worldview it was such a
huge permission slip for me to to shift
my reality from like oh i'm an atheist
so i don't know to oh okay now there's
something bigger like there's something
going on
with banting you and
like guys like you it's just
have been going up
very well
nice so
there's in your specific case there's a
lot of catalysts that then created the
seeking
spark
and drive
so it's probably not going to be
guaranteed that everybody young
will
be sparked even though they'll have
access to spiritual truth that is
disseminated via video content
at their fingertips anytime they want
the thing is is that will they be able
to parse through all the noise and find
that signal
that's probably one of the big questions
so so as much as because with what
you're sharing
it's clear that you had a lot of
catalysts that then sparked that pursuit
of truth so young people may
have
especially growing up in the times like
right now just feel like the freedom is
being limited and so they might wonder
well
how to liberate myself from the
contracted feelings of what feels like
the matrix control system
and so then that might be one of the
most common
catalysts for young people
is i will pursue spirituality
consciousness non-duality
as fast as possible
because i don't believe in any of the
matrix control structures i'll pursue
decentralization i'll pursue abundance
i'll live and imagine and breathe that
that's really exciting
and you can also see like kobe does a
huge uh collective catalyst because a
lot of people i know have been going
through like sound faces because it
doesn't really matter like where you're
at
if you are locked down in your like
house for a few months and can't do the
stuff you used to do it
it will it will create catalyst and
maybe they don't i don't see it that
consciously yet but people will get into
like trauma work and improving
themselves and creating abundance from
the for themselves and like not
following the the matrix structures of
oh you need to do this you need to study
you need to get a job you need to earn
money you need to fill the house
like this stuff is it's going down
faster and faster it seems true to be
that's just a projection from like the
past generation and actually it doesn't
feel right for me to do this
yeah
yeah because it perpetuates the old
patterns and the old infrastructures
and
young people especially know that they
they don't want to
that they don't want to
fall into
what keeps self-knowledge inhibited or
restricted
yeah
so that's the priority is self-knowledge
capital s self
knowledge above everything else
and how much joy and peace that that
brings
yeah as you said like happiness is the
number one priority for whatever you
think you want
like being happy being peaceful being
joyful is always the underlying
principle and currently there's a lot of
protection oh like this is going to give
me happiness because i have been told so
and currently i don't have access to
let's say
like i don't know a huge mansion or a
lot of money because i'm young
but even if you don't get it or even if
you get it like there will be a
realization no actually it doesn't
fulfill me like there is still something
missing and i don't know how to get it
what is it what is the missing piece
what am i missing like the mainstream is
not communicating this it's not told
it's not teach at school
but there has to be something to this
existence
it can't be it can't be that simple that
like nobody knows
that's also about secure to me like
everything everyone is going through
this world like if they knew but if you
really look at it nobody has a clue
nobody else ignorant
so you'd say that the
the internet
is
one of the biggest
catalysts for young people to be able to
find truth and what would you suggest
for for
them how to find signal
just go with what resonates and be like
the biggest factor for me was open
mindedness
like really check out every angle
if you resonate with psychedelics do
your research take psychedelics they are
super powerful if you resonate with a
spiritual teacher like really get to
know them be open-minded for what you
have to say like maybe there's some
truth in it how can you say you would
know for sure if you don't even check it
out
really try every angle for every teacher
see what
resonates and also what works for you
what really helps you to be more happy
to be more peaceful
and you will know it will be obvious for
you like if i'm if i was in this state
one year ago i would have been surprised
like how is this possible how can i be
this often how can i speak this freely
how can i be i got this broadcast i
super excited to be here and it's it's
all possible like there are no
limitations
if you believe it if you follow your
resonance if you go if you do it
then sky's the limit
okay so following what resonates in
pursuit of
truth whatever it is
through whatever means it is okay
how about the people around you
and the
and your friends
how has it been for them because if
you're 20 and you're already pursuing
this you probably also have some other
young friends that are also
seeking and so how is it working out for
them
yeah i don't have really close contact
to the people i used to be in school
with
and i moved two months ago so i'm like
in a new environment and i'm just seeing
how it all unfolds
but yeah i see a lot of suffering in
them
and
maybe they don't know it yet how how is
like
how they can change their life and also
in my past i have seen not that crown
that you could say and not that
streamlined of okay how can i
communicate this and also coming a lot
from okay i need validation for like my
metaphysical truth then
so
i don't know how they perceive it but i
see a lot of suffering i see a lot of
potential i also see a lot of
open-mindedness and interest in topics
that are not that well accepted
so it's
it's a exciting time
yeah like how you talked about
open-mindedness being a huge key
i like how you talked about uh
seeing through the need to be seen it's
very important
liberating oneself of that trap
of wanting to be seen
nice
[Music]
oh what's coming up like being then
being an example or even talking to guys
like you who have you know this journey
and like it's it's like a download if i
talk to someone uh one-on-one and he is
it's like he's deconstructing my mind
especially in no limit society
i have had a lot of times when i was
talking like in one-on-one calls
like the
acceleration acceleration is huge
because
they have been on the journey as well
for sometimes even centuries and even
the talking to them is like straight
knowledge in my brain like it's one hour
full of content like and learning
from 10 years it's just amazing
and
there are all there are so many
possibilities to do this for example
if you join nls
and you are serious about this there are
a lot of people who are willing to help
you there are some sessions that
continue every week you can ask
questions so that's also a big one
that's coming in the next month
hey so you feel like you found a pretty
strong spiritual community with no limit
society
yeah
from my humble opinion it's probably the
the most like holistic and
all-encompassing community currently
available on earth
at least with the information i have
gathered so yes
nice
yeah like really covering all of the
bases really well
actually doing the work of purification
i can give a few examples on how it was
especially powerful for me
so yeah
like the the big cat like the big thing
that really is accelerating our
dictators and having contact to people
who are really evolved and really
purified and also really you can say
enlightened
so
it has been only two months and the
biggest things for me were like unrux
cleaning your stuff up like the
five different points of health and
fitness your physical space your state
of being your relationships and your
administration of life
and an example for me has been like
that's how i found the direct belief who
i am is not okay
and that was also like the one
where i was coming from okay you need to
validate me for what i'm saying or i
need to be like i received in a certain
way when talking to certain people it
means something about me if they react
in a certain way which is just not true
and i found the root of like my my
school time when i was a little bit like
where i didn't like my body and i just
didn't allow myself to express
authentically because i thought okay now
my true self like they don't like who i
would be which is which is so arrogant
if you look at it because
if you are created like by this one god
or source or however you want to call it
then every like every particle is like
this handcrafted thing by this one
infinite intelligence and it's arrogance
to say no this one is not okay like
it's so serious
and
yeah it gave me it gave me the
motivation to to call
old people i haven't talked to anybody
and really comes from this place of
self-worth and confidence
and
that was also like a huge insight
because in my mind i was still relating
on the level of
who i was before then when i talked to
like a year ago to someone
and through the conversation and through
the embodiment of the new state there
was like a dropping away of so much lag
belief and so much contraction
so this has been like a huge liberation
and
it was so free
so good yeah
i love hearing that yeah especially how
uh doing the cleanup sort of gives a
yeah especially how doing the cleanup
gives a
a lot of insight into
where we're contracted or where we're
conditioned or
where we
still aren't free
and when we actually do the work we do
things like find out this core lack
belief that it comes up and then
um that's great so
and i love how you how your you know
your core lack belief and as well as you
know many people um
with the i'm not worthiness it's funny
because it's like
like you described that everything is
this
existence consciousness bliss
except you
yeah
it's so funny
everything
everything is
yeah
yeah infinity
endlessly
actualizing
potential
but you're not right
yeah
it's such a funny one especially like in
the spiritual community
because they're also it's often lacking
like the
self-empowering part and even if you had
like this mystical experiences into you
see this they are still like this place
of unworthiness in oneself and
it's so deep-rooted i think in a lot of
spiritual communities and
it's so funny
yeah and another way to
to say it is that
the
sense of self or the
the lower case s the
sense of identity
um has been assumed to be a person in
the body
and
so then
if you know yourself as infinity you
know yourself as always ultimately
worthy
um
but if you have a contracted sense of
self in the body you will think of
yourself as
as potentially unworthy or as separate
from other people as separate from your
from yourself as god or source
and
so that seems to be again at the very
top of
of uh as buddha said independent
origination that
you this very first link either you know
impermanence and no self and suffering
or you don't
and if you don't
then you're gonna have you're gonna make
a sense of self and you're gonna be
ignorant and then all of your action is
gonna come from that ignorant place
so it really all starts from that like
for example you growing up the only
reason you even had to pursue
spirituality was because
you gained a bunch of onion layers of
conditioning and separation just like me
and so many others
so you can see the most accelerating
spiritual path is actually where you
don't build up any of the conditions
or separations
yeah
like this one is
because if you don't build any layers
you also don't have really catalyst and
you don't have that much lesson to learn
like for example if you take that off
one and fourth density where like a an
average incarnation is like i think 90
000 years
and there is not that much learning in
that lifespan and for example my journey
has been conscious before like 10 months
and the growth and the knowledge that
has been gained in this profound amount
of time is just mindfulness so it's also
an important part to build up this
layout to gain catalyst and
to have there like the chance to grow
spiritually speaking
yeah it's an important point that all of
the layers of conditions and separation
actually are
generative of catalysts that then
are our school
and so
without the buildup of conditions
then there are uh less
spiritual catalysts but there still are
at least in the sense of
the actualization of the potential not
necessarily the dissolving or
deconstructing of identity
so there's a different style of of
expression of the one
so it's like the empowerment expression
of the one let's say
so the enlightenment expression only has
to happen if the onion layers are even
built up then they have to be
deconstructed
but the empowerment
the fireworking the creativity there's
still going to be catalysts there
you'll still
you'll still have all different types of
situations that
along that
the actualization of a unique gift that
you're blueprinted for
that um that will come up
like uh even though you might know
yourself as infinity when you have to do
taxes
you might get a little
upset and
that'll be a great catalyst is uh
is yeah your level of
frustration with your with your taxes
so
yeah it's really interesting to talk
about this kind of evolution because i
think taxes
are just here in third density and like
in 12th density i i can't imagine that
there are you have to do taxes or
something like that
it's just relevant because we built up
this uh egoic layers of the onion and
because we haven't been actualizing our
full potential as a collective if we
would have been like
fully exercised
would be abundant all over their earth
and nobody would have a problem of
discount
yep
so
probably a good time to talk about how
internal and exterior just mirror each
other
and how they feed back into each other
so all of the
past
couple centuries on
the centralization of the money supply
energy
have created more of a
separation
but now we're going through a
decentralization of all of that
so as
we wake up
and deconstruct ourselves that
that's mirrored in what we built because
we're not building from a place of
separation but from a place of wholeness
also
as we experience more decentralized
architectures that also feeds back into
our consciousness waking up
so talk about that and then talk about
um
how things like ripple or xrp how they
play into
um
shambhala into
the enlightened civilization on this
planet
very nice
so
i like to imagine
like the that the
interior and the internal interaction
like influence etc it's like a
loop because you're referencing the
external and the external is referencing
the internal and so it goes like a
circle
and
if there are more opportunities for
example in the external world like nls
or certain communities
then you will have greater access to
this and you will be able to like
evolve
more accelerated
and if you evolve my accelerators you
are able to create from that accelerated
place and you will create external
structures and more and more people can
have access to this external structures
and
they will gain momentum in the internal
group
and yeah so it's an exponential growth
and
it's going to be interesting in the next
months and here
and for example the financial system
like
money has been
pretty much controlled you could say by
big institutions
and
the normal
like the normal
human had to work for it and there was
like this oh no it's not enough for
everyone and
you have to achieve this you have to do
this to
to have enough
which is absurd
and
for example ripple
they are
really into decentralized finances and
they have a coin called xrp
and it's designed to be a british
currency
because in my opinion everything is
getting more and more digital
in this for example central banks switch
to
cbdc's which are central banks digital
currencies yeah
like
central like a digital euro or something
like that that you just have to
you don't have to print money anymore
it's just all online and i see i see
that's coming also the scope it like
everything is getting more contactless
like you pray with pay with your credit
card
so that's something that's becoming and
there are a few
points where this also will
immensely accelerate like the human
potential for example there are around i
think 1.7 billion unbanked people on
this planet right now and with ripple
everyone who has a mobile phone
if this gets integrated has access to
the financial system so there's a huge
financial inclusion for everyone to
participate and for everyone to have
like opportunities
and with the opportunities you also can
ask for a signal and search for truth
and gain like internal momentum and then
the external reflects that again
also like there are a lot of fees when
you send money for poor people over fees
like
you have to pay let's say ten dollars at
the fee
and if there's a transaction with xrp
it's very very cheap and you won't lose
that much money and like ten dollars for
a poor human
could be really life-changing
for them too okay i don't have to worry
right now like this ten dollars more
every month or a week
they will be
immensely helpful and now i can
concentrate on the important stuff like
i can pass the sickness i can try to be
happy like i have enough now there's
enough abundance to survive them and
survival is still like the the most
important thing for human beings if
survival is like transit
then the acceleration then the
activation of potential can start
mm-hmm
yeah it's exciting thinking about the
1.8 or whatnot billion people that are
unbanked
leap frogging over the centralized
banking
infrastructure and going straight into
the crypto wallet space
but why wouldn't they go
to bitcoin and ethereum why do you think
sxrp is
the key
because i think the structures like the
current structures like the banking
system and the government they won't be
like they won't break down that path i
think there's going to be a process and
there's going to be an internal change
for this system and ripple is working
with these banks and they they are
integrating as i said like if there is a
cbdc
for
let's say
uh
crafty
trades uh cbdc then xrp is like the
the background of moving value like you
can send your
euro the digital euro and xp is like the
moving of value to and digital dollar
and that's why i see it to be such
important because they work with the
banks they work with the government they
are involved they are highly connected
also it is very far
it is
really cheap
and it also sends it's also transparent
and it's not that energy like bitcoin
for example uses a lot of energy it's
not like no one pays with bitcoin it's
slow it's expensive
and if someone has seen like the
pictures of the mining there's still a
lot of energy going into this and that's
basically wasted energy why why would
you waste this energy
because i think climate change and
things like that will be more and more
important for the mask like for the
collective
that's why i think xrp is a great
representation of the
new system and the way things are going
to be
so xrp is actually a bridge between the
centralized banking and the
decentralized
future
so xrp is working with the centralized
banks on the cbdc's
the centralized bank digital currencies
is that right they're providing the uh
the the underlying technology
yeah that's the uh that's the plan at
least
like
it's still you can't really say if
that's
they are indicators of this because they
have a lot of partnerships with
partnerships with banks and you see how
connected like the the ceos are with a
lot of financial financial leaders
that's this still speculative you could
say
but if you
go into this deeper let's say if the
genius down for a podcast
and then it will make more and more
sense because there are a lot of points
and a lot of
connectedness also to the spiritual
community
so
so the idea is that the cd or the the
cbdc
centralized bank digital currency
that
that having an underlying technology of
ripples
will then make it easier as people
switch to the digital us dollar or the
digital euro etc
it will make it easier for the
integration to happen where people begin
using like crypto wallets
it'll make it easier for people to make
the transition to other
even non-centralized
digital currencies
yeah also xop is not really centralized
because there's not like a power
structure that has control over it it's
not that ripple ripple has like i think
five percent of the of the control and
there are also
another companies and
other people who have the power like
they can't decide to make something they
are like dependent on other parties
and it's like yeah it's the the
underlying structure of
central bank's digital currency
and i don't know how the switch will
going to happen but let's say if
it's seen that this money is more
efficient it's faster and cheaper it's
better for the climate and there's a
different decision from a government
okay they will switch it we will switch
like printed money to digital money
then yes this could be the underlying
structure
i see so as printed money switches to
digital money
the use of xrp
for the cbdcs
will transition people more and more
towards
using
cryptocurrencies
that are also not
made by centralized banks
so this is almost like a middle step
like i can
like i can like i can set myself up
right now
with
with cbdc's
like having digital us dollars or which
i already do in my ledger in my
in my bank it's just a bunch of digits
and so then what would it look like for
those digits let's say a thousand us
dollars or a thousand euro to get
incorporated with
xrp and and cbdc
what does that look like
um
is this a harder technical question
i i don't have that much a clue about
that i have to say
like i would imagine that there wouldn't
be that much difference because it's
like running the background system we
have no clue how we two are connected
right now we have no clue about the
technicalities that is like that is
needed for us to have this conversation
for our phones to work like we just see
the the surface level of this and i
think from the technical view from a
like the science shoot there wouldn't be
much of a change i don't know how the
exchange of like
because as you said your number on their
bank account is already you could save
digital
so there wouldn't be that much of a
change it just would be
only digital payment like
it that just wouldn't be printed money
anymore and the underlying
infrastructure of how the system works
would be changed so there wouldn't be
that much of a noticeable change for
like a normal human being
i i envision that the
transition will look like
um like frictionless p to p
exchange um
frictionless person-to-person exchange
of value
um with no intermediaries
so if i want to send you money i just
send you money frictionlessly without
any
middleman
through either unique
unique keys or
and then
from there i can access any
of the different coins
with my wallet
where certain coins will be used for
specific things
and other coins would be more general
use
so bitcoin seems to be a most general
coin for use
and then something a little bit more
specialized
that is used
specifically for like
[Music]
art nfts or something
it will be a different
style of coin
so i'll be able to
to frictionlessly see my wallet that
would have my
the total amounts of those different
coins and also to be able to send back
and forth to different people and to be
able to list my nft assets or whatever
else that i that i own at the same time
and
to have everything be
without
middleman
so everything is just p to p
do you see it like that too
yeah
sounds like
pumpkin
i have something sounds so good doesn't
it
but
it sounds so much better like nobody
wants
to
nobody wants to
like
nobody wants to feel like they're
getting [ __ ]
you know
they just most simply put nobody wants
to feel like they're getting [ __ ]
um everyone wants their basic needs met
everyone wants freedom everyone wants
peace everyone wants happiness that's
without a doubt and so
and so we have all these trillions of
dollars that are currently locked in
high net worth families
and
in
the
2200 billionaires on the planet there's
literally trillions of dollars locked up
and they don't know where to put the
money
well to find
the best places to provide the best
places and to put it in those places for
maximizing planetary basic needs to
build out the planet's next shambhalas
to increase
freedom
joy peace actualization of artistic
potential awakening
this is the only way forward
so to
to wake up every single day
envisioning
that we all already are at this
enlightened civilization where
everything is all the basic needs are
met all of the um the whole collective
is awake and enlightened and and
bringing forth art and bringing forth
prosperity
has been such a big key um
and it's it's the only way forward the
only way forward is to envision that
it's already done
and then to just trust that
that the collective
intention especially with programs like
nls that as
five
300
a thousand ten thousand people are all
holding a collective intention of
shambhala is already done
that that number increases to a hundred
thousand and a million and more and more
people move into this paradigm of
of fourth density love light
consciousness
it's exciting
no
yeah i always see like the the abundance
is already there like the distribution
distribution is just [ __ ] because also
a lot of the
the powerful people i don't i don't know
the percentage of which them
of which are like service to
self-oriented and really wanted to be
this way and
like what the fantasies felt confused
and think that that will give them
happiness and in reality they would love
to see like
the whole planet prospering and
yeah
let's see how this unfolds and i'm also
certain the more and more people hold
this vision and the more like the
suffering gets because their own
structures are coming down and they are
coming down faster and faster and faster
and the conscious will be more and more
noticeable and if we hold this space and
if we hold like this reality
then more people will be like okay why
wouldn't i be part of this reality it's
ethic it's amazing it's possible so why
am i holding myself back why am i
choosing my suffering because it's all
self-created
mm-hmm
so this reminds me of uh
how from the top down in terms of like
the planet's most wealthy you bring up a
good point which is
polarization towards service to self so
it might be true that
there's going to be a a good amount of
those 2200 billionaires that just
that don't really care
about anyone but themselves
besides their contracted sense of self
and then from the bottom up
you're going to have more and more
grassroots awakening happening so from
the top down you'll have sts and sto
polarized wealth
trying to make moves in um
the planet both waking up and falling
asleep and then from the bottom up
we'll have both people
that are waking up and staying asleep
and so it's up to us to awaken the lion
inside
awaken the lion inside of all of our
other selves
so
if if we get
that this is self
capitalized talking to itself
god talking to god
source talking to source consciousness
talking to consciousness
and if we can just relax into that
we can tune into the no separation
we can tune into the no lack
you can tune into the perfection
and this is exactly what
this collective seeks
the obliteration of all separation
conditioning
all basic needs being met
so it's going to come from two places
it's going to come from think content
like this
where the grassroots is going to be able
to be like oh yeah
consciousness talking to itself god
talking to itself hmm cool i can see
that way more often i can make my
identity that more
and then bang bang bang bang bang
it'll also come from top down it'll also
come from top down where you have
you have things like the united nations
sustainable development goal so more of
the planet's consciousness is as is at
least oriented towards oh there's still
almost a billion people without access
to clean water so we'll still be
galvanizing our resources toward that
and then also
if you just look at what we have to do
nowadays to travel
that's the service to self-polarized top
down force
so
if you have
to if you have to take
vaccines and booster shots
very deep
nasal swabs
being documented everywhere you go
being manipulated by
media propaganda
24 7.
there's no lack of
polarized news
being promulgated on the internet across
a myriad of different
television stations and websites
if the countries still think that
they're separate from each other which
is the dumbest thing ever
so stupid
um
then that's going to increase
geopolitical conflict
so countries
both being able to recognize and like
chill in their
like independent traditions and their
and like the culture and be like yeah
it's beautiful like we love
the celebration of your traditions
but you're just not separate from the
rest of earth
um everything on earth is one
so it's all layered like that
so you'll have an the these seeming
individuals but they're all capitalist
self they're all god
just like you'll have these independent
independent seemingly independent
countries
but they're all gaia they're all the
planets
energy
[Music]
waking up to this
is it
[Music]
it's so simple
so let's play in the future like five
ten years from now
fabian let's say that we have
other young people
waking up they're like fifth they're
like 10 years old right now
what are they using to wake up how are
they finding the truth
in 10 years from now or now
let's say that the 10 year olds
10 years from now
the 10 year olds both now beginning to
find truth as well as in five years and
10 years when they are finding truth and
getting aligned to spiritual communities
what do you feel like they're using as
their tools are they still
using tick-tock are they using oculus
are they using virtual reality are they
using how are they deconstructing their
identity
how are they deconditioning themselves
how are they finding the spiritual
communities
[Music]
yeah
i mean it's it's hard to forecast like
5-10 years because in my opinion it will
the change will be radical and drastic
and
not recognizable so 10 years from now
it's really like
i don't know but i think the internet
will be still a huge component like to
be connected and to have the possibility
to talk to everyone around the globe and
if the internet
structure gets like more developed there
will be even more possibilities and
more like people like us making content
and offering like one-on-one sessions
and even talking to your peers if they
are interested and
being more reflective of one another
like really being mirror-like i see this
in
younger people especially like to be
able to say honestly like okay i
perceived you that way and you could
like change that and not take that
personally so there are a lot of factors
playing into this also the
educational system
so
yeah
it's so multi-dimensional and there are
so many facets to this
i just see the acceleration and the
growth at the perfection in all of
that's the place i'm coming from
also another point that came up before
like how the acceleration can be really
rapid for example like an individual
that has a company and that has more
influences
and if someone like this awakens then
the
like the
the spreading of truth and the spreading
of the information will also really
accelerate and that's an example of like
a german
ceo with a huge fitness company and he
took psychedelics a few times and he had
this realization of oh everything is one
and
he just changed his complete company
with that he turned into vegan for
example and his company is going
conscious and i see this more and more
and
this will have so huge impact
like
even if they like other vlc okay he is
more happy now his company is also
running better because it will be more
and more requested like conscious
companies will be more and more
receptive so this is all
like influencing each other and i see i
trust you so much potential
i love that example of even just a
simple
awakening experience through entheogens
or whatever it might be
triggering a huge
difference in the way that one
shows up in the world where you're not
coming from a place of separation
anymore but you're coming from a place
of wholeness and that way your whole
business all of your employees
everything are then
vibrating more and more at the wholeness
they're vibrating more and more at
unity
yeah that feels so good
i was going to ask you what's your
prediction like what tools do you think
we will be using in the future
um i see
like the pixar style um
movie um for awakening
like like soul except like next levels
um i see that being big
as a tool
um i see
i see like a vr pedagogy where you just
tap in and then it basically shows you
all the different layers of conditioning
that have been built up and how to see
through all of the what you've created
as a sense of identity and self and
separation and
and then it shows you how to recognize
very simply true capitalist self self
realization god realization and how
you're dancing with yourself on this
collective and as the universe
[Music]
yeah i'd say those two are probably the
most prominent um
and then yeah i would also say
entheogens as well so i think more and
more people are going to start taking
magic mushrooms and lsd and
and
and all that those things are doing is
they're just decentralizing your
connectome so like where you've had a
a tight
neurological sense of self that's
located behind the eyes
all that magic mushrooms or these
different psychedelics antigens are
doing is they're just showing you that
that tight sense of self is an illusion
that that tight sense of self is just
something that you've turned into a
constructed ossified pattern over the
last couple of decades of your life
and instead all you have to do is
liberate yourself from that contracted
sense of identity to being the entire
universe
into being
in god infinity dancing with yourself
so
i also see
awakened um
like awakened communities and
influencers i see that being a big part
of this as well
um
so like all of the shambhalas that we're
building like with no limit society also
all of the
influencers that are sort of waking up
and wondering like why is none of this
making making me happy
um and then they become they become um
they start making music and videos
around their own awakening experiences
and then sharing that with their
millions of followers
so that's another exciting one
yeah that's what i would summarize it as
yeah also psychedelics are like for me
one of the biggest factors like because
they have such a huge potential
and the risk is can be really
minimalized for example if there's a
trip sitter like us who knows like what
they are going through and who can just
hold the space of love and accept them
and just be there present with them
and because it's self-created and they
can tune into that space then the trip
will get more and more in that direction
and it's just so powerful that's one of
the things i'm really excited for like i
would love to explore more in this
direction
for sure
yeah i agree that one of the biggest
tools for the acceleration of
spirituality will be anthogens
and
you know fabian this is probably a good
place to also mention to you
the reason why we use entheogen instead
of psychedelic is psychedelic means mind
manifesting but entheogen means
unleashing god or the divine within
like my definition for psychedelics is
revealing the soul like at least that's
the greek translation that i know so i
think both are great ones
cool
i like that so if you if
definition of psychedelic is revealing
the soul then i like that too
um that's good and then
i do really like still that entheo gen
right
n theo gen right inside god generating
right you you really awaken to god
within
um
um very good
i see that being huge
also
there's so much centralization of uh of
consciousness on on in this collective
it's so cute
like with all of these uh
contracted senses of identity like
behind the eyes and like
and all of the suffering that that
causes because we see ourselves as
separate
um
it's been really fun waking up to this
do you feel like you
consistently
um feel
self with itself god with itself
consciousness with itself do you can you
do you feel like you're abiding in your
awakening already at age 20
it's hard for me like
there comes the question of what is like
the the definitions of self-realization
for example because it's obvious for me
that there is only oneness and that
there is no separation and when i look
at this meet you like it's not more me
like there is no there's no duality here
that's like the other two here and
me speaking quote unquote
is
exactly the same as you speaking for me
and i can tune into this realization
nice but yeah
yeah there are there are definitely like
little things that can put me off
sometimes but
it's so obvious because when i get
defensive or when i get triggered like i
notice immediately because it doesn't
feel good
yeah
yeah you can tell that that's the
emotional guidance system bringing you
back to
abidence or remembrance of self
nice that's cool yeah you you even like
quite eloquently um speak about your
realization and which is great
yeah i would love a few pointers in this
direction because
their trajectory like where it is going
is really interesting to me and
i consider you to be more enlightened
you could say so can you talk about it
like where's the trajectory of awakening
going and
when do you know that you are there or
whatever you tell me you want to use
well
you cannot see that
i can't read it
i'll uh i'll walk us through it um
so
in the top left corner you see the
standard perception
which is
that my sense of self is
located behind my eyes and that i have
these thoughts and that i have these
emotions and i have this attention
that
is
directed outward at an objective world
so one of the first shifts in awakening
is in the to the top right corner
which is to the witness identifying as
that which is aware of things
so then
it's like a background it's like you
become aware of the screen
you've heard that analogy right the
screen and the module questions or the
paper and the and the writing on the
paper right stuff like that
right
so so some people say that this is
like uh realization
you know i did i did too for a little
bit
until things opened up more for me
and then you shift into big mind which
is right below that identifying with
everything
so like your sense of self becomes
more and more clearly everything so the
basically the subject object duality
collapses
so whereas like in the previous stage
there was awareness of objects
or awareness of modulations of sensation
let's say
now there's a well
subject object duality has just
collapsed completely
and then you shift into the bottom left
corner which is more of a sense of no
self no felt sense of i in any part of
experience
this is where you could say that it
the the sense of self
the lower case s sense of self
has been so seen through
that this is sort of the beginnings of
the field recognition
like
everything being energy
modulating
everything being
energy in flux or energy dancing or
in you being that and not being a
separate sense of self or even being the
capital s god self so meaning like the
third stage and the fourth stage here
are very much like
capital s self and no self are like two
sides of the same coin when you realize
that there's no self you realize the
capital s self but then there's a
deepening of that where you begin
recognizing that it's also you know
like this is it talking to itself but
then that becomes your like lived
experience of it with itself but without
a center
like it just being energy with itself
and that's where this no self and no
center attention without direction come
in because you're not directing your
attention at all anymore but it's just
without direction like it just feels
more and more like
like a natural state of existence
without a center
so
this is uh what you could say are some
of the
visualizations of
the breakdown of the awakening journey
do you have any thoughts about it
i mean i
can't see it that great
for me it's
because i'm not sure where this all is
leading and
for me it's hard to like make the twitch
for example to continuous terms like to
this because then senior is like for
example making a clear distinction still
for like the absolute
and extra example don't see the absolute
in this um
yeah
but can you bridge this like to the
terms of
how pantene you describe the whole
awakening process would that be possible
for you
well the absolute is the infinite
reality prior to this universe
this universe is made of awareness love
lighter satchit ananda
this is both the absolute talking to
itself but the absolute is also the
infinite reality beyond this universe
was that helpful
yeah i i guess it's like from bending
your shoe but i just can't bridge like
the two
examples like for example this is more
like frank yang style i would say and
for me it's hard to to make the bridge
between for example frank yang and the
bentino that's that's still like i think
i don't i don't see the that they are
fully like
matching that's something that i am
currently like that's my stage
and i'm open because i don't know where
it leads and i won't like finalize
myself to say oh that's the end or
whatever
so i'm
i'm curious did you already have like a
um a full pop-out experience into the
absolute
yeah i would say grocking it
yeah
and i would also say what you say about
the blend between um ben and frank
there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of similarity but there is
some difference and then i'm doing my
best to sort of synthesize those as well
um
so
i don't really see them as that much
different
and
i think that that's probably been my
biggest
my biggest like positive trade of uh of
my expression has been the fact that i
i find the
similarities or the synthesis between
things
and
um
yeah i mean it's it's only gonna get
more and more clean like in terms of the
synthesis of the two and um being able
to like visualize it like this is really
hard it's like on a 2d sheet of paper um
you know and i'm talking about bringing
this into virtual reality and turning it
into a pedagogy
um and then blending
this you know andrew houston has also
talked about like
what bentino talks about and what
several other spiritual teachers talk
about as being like a triple layered um
like like a source style awareness so
you have the human you have awareness
and you have source
it's like a triple layer
and
you have to basically blend that with
this
like decentralization of of
consciousness you have to blend it with
self-realization you have to blend it
with
no self
blend it with divine love which is the
fabric of existence so there's like a
devotional
aspect to the what is-ness then there's
also the blending with the the clean-up
work in the
in purification there's a blending that
of blending of that with the
imagineering like the walt disney style
like symbols archetypes like
choosing your absolute highest
expression shambhala whatever your main
superhero character is and and feeling
more and more of that every day with
your vibration
so there's a blending of all of those
that we'll be putting into pedagogy
for sure
you see there's a lot of components
right
yeah
oh yeah but they're not different
they they are and they're not right they
all point to the same thing and like
refining the same thing
but they are like different sides of the
mountain
did that resonate
yeah it makes sense for me like
i also see the the similarities but
they're still like some for example
frank clearly makes like sores and no
source but it's like really all the same
and for example benting is like okay
awareness is the first person of the
absolute and you still like the absolute
is more you could say absolute it's more
permanent it's more real
that's for for example a name like
distinction that i get out of them
well you'll also hear
um ben
talk about the simultaneity of how
the absolute is both um beyond awareness
and the absolute is also this
and that's the simultaneity that's
non-duality that's you know
so they both do point to that
you know that same thing at the same
time
and
i think that that's that's a key is to
realize that this is the absolute
dancing with itself and yet also at the
same time the absolute is the infinite
reality beyond even this universe right
it makes sense doesn't it
yeah it's
like the intellectual framework is
totally here for me so
but it's still
for example i
i wouldn't say that i
can stamp staircase for me
in my experience it feels like there is
you could say
a void or whatever it's like it's
intuition like
i mean it's not behind my head because i
see that just a container that shows the
assumption but yeah it feels like
avoiding infinite reality i just can't
describe it so
do you think i'm sensing the absolute
yeah just keep tuning in to what you're
feeling
keep going yeah it's beautiful
like that's the that's your lifeline
you know to the creator that's is your
impulse for truth
so
as you as you dive into that more and
more you'll gain more clarity
about what you're realizing about what
you're experiencing about um
about how that
relates to the different spiritual
traditions and the different spiritual
teachers that you follow that type of
thing
yeah thanks a lot for the clarification
it really helps
nice bro
cool
nice um
this has been fun fabian
[Music]
totally
thanks for coming on the show do you
have any uh other thoughts that you want
to close with
it feels complete to me
cool
yeah it does feel really good
this was fun together maybe we'll uh
maybe we'll have a chance in
a couple weeks or what not to chat with
genie about xrp soon
let's see what unfolds
let's see what unfolds
yeah and also it was just fun getting to
know you more and
and uh feeling our vibe together was
nice and just becoming closer friends
it's really cool
well that's what i love about analysts
like connecting to the like-minded
people like-minded souls and
that's immediately like a connection
because you can feel the transparency
you can feel the the honest laughter
yeah
we'll have the link to no limits society
of course in the bio below so definitely
check that out fam
thanks for tuning in we love you so much
drop us a comment with your thoughts on
the episode
like the video share it if you feel like
that there are people that it would
resonate with subscribe to the channel
if you haven't yet
so much love
fabian thanks again brother thank you
thanks for having me
sweet i'll uh i'll end the show and then
you and i can stay in the studio okay